I would have been drunk at work I've
been tipsy I've nothing drunk in the
work shutters holy crap oh okay
dry eyes look coolness this is what
happens when you fall into a vat of
Everclear oh I've never been this drunk
at work the second you move your head
you toe like reestablish where you are
you really see how crazy it is to try to
even walk you look like an idiot we're
going to do a variety of activities
throughout the office and we're going to
see how our motor skills compare from
when we're drunk versus when we're sober
oh oh that's not a down down little
depth perception was horrible I think
you missed a renter oh gosh your
syphilis I think I just kind of kind of
like trust oh I'm sick you need to be
sober to make coffee you don't
yeah this is so hot
mom wasn't just over it my brain was not
working with my lens pretty easy for
your friend
shoveling something in my mouth got it
putting the keys in the door to me was
the hardest part
come on you gotta pick up step wow I'm
amazing a bingo first one in wins still
amazing I cannot walk a straight line
but you're just not on the line yeah
we're two straight I can walk a straight
line
absolutely oh you're all penguin yeah
you have to look at your beside the line
you got it though real life situation
fail I might not be able to walk
now you're married yeah oh I wasn't
fooling anyone like I might have walked
the line with a compliment like just get
in the car Oh what was ridiculous this
gracious nothing I need air ah I'm gonna
let anybody near a car they were this
drunk
Oh Alan there's a car coming oh crap
that made me feel like I was in some
scary Willy Wonka tunnel of death I can
barely see oh my gosh that was tough
this was a horrible we're all pretty
Tara yeah basically just spent the whole
day nauseous yeah it was damn near
impossible to do anything made life very
difficult
it sucks it was really terrible when you
take away the confidence that you get
from being me Bree ated you really see
how crazy it is to try to even walk I
don't think anyone should get drunk and
then decide to do tasks if I ever caught
my kids getting this ride
may be dead and there one in three good
morning you now
it's our turn to God